[Music]
you're not hearing things cardi b has
her own take on beyonce's new song oh
snappity snap snap it's break my soul
with a tipsy twist some deep penetration
no masturbation
yeah
you don't wanna you don't break my heart
you won't break my heart
you don't break my heart
you don't break my heart on everybody
everybody
everybody
everybody cardi goes full-on acapella on
instagram live singing a
not-safe-for-word version of beyonce's
house music bop from her upcoming
renaissance album
[Music]
while the rapper initially went live to
promote her own music cardi gets a
little wasted dancing to bee's hit
[Music]
the watt pit maker is seen downing
back-to-back shots some from her own
brand of alcoholic whipped cream others
straight from a bottle of tequila
at one point cardi really gets hyped
rapping to what she thinks is the best
part of the song
[Music]
leave it to cardi to always keep us
entertained but she also knows her
liquor limits not superstars for me
[ __ ] too much like i cannot the racy
rendition catches the attention of her
man offset who leaves a comment on the
ig live that cardi quickly responds to
i'll say
i love how happy you are three minutes
let's go i'll be happier if you give me
some
well okay we do know the three-minute
countdown led to cardi dropping her new
song called hot
featuring kanye who she briefly forgets
to mention in a couple of seconds hi
dropping with little dirk
and um and uh
yay west kanye west bye i'm out go to
apple spotify youtube
these are right listen to music at [ __ ]
that we going up girl
blame it on the alcohol but cardi does
give yay his praise during her press run
for the song on new music daily i had a
lot of conversations with kanye west
i learned so much about him and he's
such a he's such an amazing sweet person
like
uh i've been feeling like i wish a lot
of people have conversations with him so
they could just see like the
the real
the him they can stop me now i've been
popping now called
cardi says she and kanye collaborated on
the song at the height of his media
storm amid his divorce drama with kim
kardashian kanye gave me this verse a
couple of months ago when he was just
you know when he was just all over the
media because you know all of this
all of the things that were going on and
um i just like how it's like i like how
his verse is like it's it's personal but
it's not that personal yeah it's like
enjoyable in the clubs that you could be
like yeah yeah you talk your big cat
still we can't get over b's club banger
and big frida who is featured on break
my soul teased the queen's new sound as
liberating
it's going to be motivation and
inspirational for all of us great club
music
great music to be on the dance floor and
feeling live and liberated and free if
there's one person queen bee has feeling
free it's definitely cardi
b
[ __ ] what's up i could sing real facts
anyways
and we back outside they said they all
stopped dating that'll say
[Music]
you